The mini net tool we have been using
in the course, is actually a example of, network
visualization, we are in fact running a, an
entire virtual network, on your laptop. When you start
mini net using the MN script, each host
in the virtual network, is a bash process. With
it's own network name space. A network name
space is kind of like a virtual machine except
it's a lot more lightweight. It's infact
called OS Level Virtualization. So, each one of
these virtual nodes, has its own view of
the network stack as shown here with these
interfaces. But it has a shared filesystem and
it's not, in fact, running it's own independent
virtual machine. The root namespace manages the communication
between these distinct virtual nodes, as well as
the switch that connects these nodes in the topology that you set up. Virtual
ethernet pairs are assigned two name spaces.
For example, S1 eth1 is assigned to an
interface in H2's network name space. And S1 eth2 is assigned to a network
name space in H3's virtual network name
space. The open flow switch effectively performs forwarding
between the interfaces in the root name
space. But because the interfaces are paired, we
get the illusion, of sending traffic, between h2
and h3. When we make modifications, to the
open flow switch, via the controller we're infact
doing that in the root name space. In
summary, virtual networks facilitate flexible, agile deployment, by
enabling rapid innovation at the pace of software.
Vender independence, and scale. We talked about the distinction
between SDN's and virtual networks, as well as various
technologies that enable virtual networks, such as virtual machines
for creating virtual nodes, and tunneling for creating virtual links.